being a part of the infinite game is not
the absence of finite games it's the
context within which those finite games
exist and when we when we think only in
short term in an infinite game like I
said you don't know what it's a part of
and at some point you start saying is
this worth it or what am I doing here is
this you know this is it becomes
exhausting quite frankly
um we have to change the analogies we
have to change the metaphors we overuse
Sports and War analogies in business
those are finite constructions think of
it more like a lifestyle right let's say
you want to be healthy and there's many
things you have to do to be healthy you
have to eat right you have to sleep you
can absolutely have arbitrary short-term
goals and if I happen to hit my goal on
the right day and the right time I'm
ecstatic but here's the joke I have to
keep exercising and eating healthy For
the Rest of My Life the game hasn't
ended just because I hit a goal what's
more interesting is what happens if you
miss your goal right you know what
happens if you miss your goal nothing
nothing happens because when you have a
vision when you have a just cause that
you're striving for you're making
constant Improvement and if you go back
to our metaphor I'm way healthier now
than I was when I started even if I
missed my goal so the two are not
mutually exclusive you can absolutely
have arbitrary goals it's very exciting
it drives people metrics are good but to
what end like what what is this all
actually building towards and that's the
vision and the just cause the primary
responsibility of a leader is to build
new leaders you know and one of the ways
we do that is we teach leadership you
know when somebody joins a company we
give them lots and lots of education on
the product and how the company works
and how the systems work and we give
them mentors and all of these things but
if we promote someone to a position of
leadership we usually give them little
to nothing and yet leadership is a skill
like any other we don't expect them to
be good at their job unless we train
them how to do their job so how do we
expect them to be good leaders we don't
train them how to be leaders you know
are we teaching things like how to give
and receive feedback how to do active
listening how to have an effective
confrontation I'd have a difficult
conversation like these are leadership
skills